started so title of my talk today is
descriptive complexity which was what I
mean in some sense we've been talking
about complexity of of evaluation of
first order formulas before but I want
to sort of cut hit on a couple of
highlights on about descriptive
complexity today so as always I'll start
with a quick review of what we've seen
in the past three lectures so we looked
at tools for establishing limits on the
expressive power of first-order
sentences and also first order theories
with a bounded number of variables right
essentially we looked at two kinds of
pebble games in the first lecture in the
second lecture we looked at linking the
expressive power of MSO to that of
finite automata which gives on the one
hand tools for studying the expressive
power of mi so like I showed you simple
consequence of proving that the
Hamiltonian cycle is not definable even
on ordered graphs and also limiting the
complexity of MSO definable properties
on decomposable structures this was
Cassell's theorem hey and then the last
lecture I looked at the complexity of
first-order logic and sparse classes of
structures using the cavity so as I said
we've been touching on the themes of
complexity so what I want to talk today
about today is sort of one other things
that was one of the motivating reasons
for studying finite bottle theory and
ways of limiting the expressive power in
the first place and that is the fact
that you can actually capture certain
complexity classes in a logical form so
the idea is descriptive complexity
provides an alternative perspective on
computational complexity
so classically in computational
complexity we measure the complexity of
problems using resources the space time
on some machine model of computation and
when we talk of the complexity of a
problem the problem is formalized as a
language that is a set of strings here
we're going to aim at talking about the
complexity of a class structures for
example collection of graphs right the
kinds of things we've been talking about
and we're going to measure the
complexity in terms of how hard it is to
describe in a certain language and of
course what's interesting is that the
tour closely connected so one thing I
should say I mean I've talked about the
evaluation problem for for first order
formulas i mean fo keon also talked to
extensively about this when we talk
about complexity and particularly now
we're going to talk about formal
definition of complexity classes
formally define the sets of strings we
already have to at some point make
explicit how start how these structures
get represented as strings you know we
don't usually want to get stuck into the
details of particular encoding but it's
good to fix it for one so I thought I'd
put it down here's what I'll assume for
example fix a three letter alphabet and
if you have a structure which is a
universe with some number of relations
fix some ordering of the universe let's
say a is a numerator they went through
a.m. and then that ordering gives for
each relation any relation of our IDK
gets represented as a bit string of
length n to the K basically you choose
it take the lexicographical ordering of
katie opals and for HK people you put
down a 0 if it's not in the relation one
if it is in the relation and so the
string representing the structure is
going to be a sequence of n ones to
indicate the size of the structure and
then these bit strings representing the
relations separated by these hashes now
the purpose of this thing over here is
simply the case that if you have no
relations we still want the size of the
string to be related to the size the
structure right that's why we don't we
write the sizing of the start the
structure sailfin you
rather than binary so now for any
vocabulary whatsoever the length of this
there's a string is bounded by some
polynomial in the in n and that's what
we care about okay one point to
highlight is I define the string
encoding of the structure a with respect
to a particular order I chose on the
elements a different choice of order
will give me a different string possibly
right so it's worth pointing out that
now we were thinking of a classical
decision problem on strings we're given
a string for a fixed let's say Phi is a
fixed formula where Wu and the problem
is given a string decide whether it
represents a structure satisfying Phi so
this has a natural invariance property
because formulas are invariant under
isomorphisms i said this right at the
beginning of the first lecture we're
concerned with properties which are
invariant under isomorphisms and so this
isomorphism of course induces an
equivalence relation on strings two
strings are equivalent if there is some
structure and two different orders which
yield these two strings as
representations of the same structure
right so any language any class of
strings were interested in is invariant
under this equivalence relation and this
equivalence relation now you can ask how
hard is it to decide this and this is of
course just isomorphism the graph
isomorphism problem is what the
complexity of this equivalence relation
is okay having said that I'm no longer
going to worry about the actual details
of my encoding of strings having you
know clicked under the hood as here and
we leave it there okay fish sure is it
created graph isomorphism you see
equally complex as any
now I is not fishing for any vegetable
early well I won't answer the question
it's clear but it is true it may require
a bit of work but it's um what is it is
a case I mean there's a by
interpretation to trip to the language
of graphs from anything's and that's
easily computable so that's right
exactly iiii think important to say any
vocabulary containing at least one
binary relation or at least one relation
of Arctic to a greater thought could be
absolutely yep okay ah so this is a
statement we've already seen a few times
it popped up in in Tolkien's
presentation and I mentioned it last
time or as well for any first-order
sentence the complexity of the problems
of when Phi is fixed the complexity
given a structure and now by giving a
structure we mean given a straight
string encoding it decide whether it
satisfies Phi we know is a logarithmic
space in polynomial time now this is
already fairly low in complexity right
but there are computationally easy
properties in log space which are not
definable in first order logic and we've
already seen them we know that you can't
say there's no first order sentence
which says that the size of a is even
that's clearly a problem in logarithmic
space when one constant space in fact
but it's not expressible in force or
logic there's no formula say in one
binary relation that defines the
transitive closure fact there's you
can't express connectivity of graphs
even undirected graphs and for
undirected graphs we know the problem is
in logarithmic space so so first order
logic is strictly weaker than
logarithmic space
if we go to a second-order logic all of
these become definable and I started
just trying to write down the
definitions we know it's all doable but
here's a formula of second-order logic
that says that the size of the universe
is even what does it say basically says
there is a binary relation be and a set
s such that B is a bad reaction but when
I said its complement oh I will leave
out the interpretation of all that but
basically that says that there is an
even number of elements and this is
because BMS are quantified this is a
format up here in the language of
equality which is what we want
transitive closure I already showed you
in same anodic universal second-order
logic you can express connectivity and
this is just the same except i now have
constants a and B to say that there is a
path from A to B rights or any set that
contains a and this close on the edge
relation contains B I essentially showed
you you can't do this in existential
melodic second-order logic if you allow
existential quantification of our binary
relation you can do you can express this
and here is my attempt are expressing it
what does this say basically i want to
say there's a path from A to B so I say
there is a set P and it's a set of edges
right that's what this has but I can't
say it's a path in first order logic but
these conditions these are first-order
conditions which guarantee that p
contains a path ok basically it says
that there's an outgoing edge from p and
incoming edge to before from a sari and
incoming edge to be and no incoming edge
to a and outgoing edge to from be in p
for everything that has an outgoing edge
it's unique for everything that has an
incoming edge it's unique and everything
other than a if it has an outgoing edge
has an incoming one and everything other
than B if it hasn't it in telling you hi
it has an outgoing one the only way you
can satisfy all these requirements is if
everything you know from a you have an
outgoing edge from B you have an
incoming edge and any other point where
there's something coming in has to have
something going out so P must be the
union of a path from A to B possibly
with some cycles around which loop
everywhere so these first order logic
for first order formulas don't rule out
the possibility of these cycles but if
they're satisfied there is a path from A
to B and so this says that's what this
says okay three color abilities another
example I've shown you before so all of
this is motivating ah fagan serum which
I suppose also here at least heard of
classify night structures is definable
by sentence of existential second-order
logic right and all those examples are
just showing you and that was the reason
for showing you could do this
existentially if and only if it's
decidable by a non-deterministic machine
in polynomial time usually summed up by
the simple equation existential
second-order logic is the same thing as
NP okay if we want to make this I mean
make a slightly more precise statement
then then that given what I've just said
what we're saying is if you have a set
of class of structures which are the
models of some formula in existential
second-order logic if and only if the
collection of strings which are code
which code structures in s is a set of
strings desirable in NP okay in
particular note this this set is always
invariant under the isomorphism relation
that I define okay um I mean I know many
of you could write down the proof of
this theorem now this is well known but
I'll just state the key points in one
slide
in one direction if you have a formula
of existential second-order logic so in
pre next normal form there exists some
relations and then theta for a first
order formula theta to decide whether a
structure satisfy given the input a you
guess in interpretations for these
relations right so you just expand the
string representing a with strings for
these relations and that's a polynomial
amount of guessing and then you just
evaluate the first order formula and
evaluating a first order formula we know
is in polynomial time so the whole thing
is an NP right that's one direction in
the other direction we're given let's
say a non-deterministic machine m and a
bound on its running time which is
polynomial P we write down the formula
which basically says there is a binary
relation which is a linear order of the
universe and then there exists relations
and you have to sort of do a bit of
coding here which code an accepting
complication of this machine m of length
p which starts with the coding of the
structure now of course the way I've
written it it looks like this formula
depends on the structure but of course
that's not what it what it means it's
you write down the axioms which ensure
that when this is interpreted in a
structure a what it is saying is that
the initial state represented by these
relations on its tape has exactly the
representation of the structure which is
interpreted and the point is again
because the length of the the
computation is bounded by a polynomial
this can all be coded in relation to fix
charity and you just have to say they
state that you know the in first order
logic that from you know one time
instance to the next it's a consistent
computation small remark about this
invariance under the order this machine
M clocked by the polynomial P might not
define a set of strings which is
invariant under the order and under this
isomorphism relation so this formula
doesn't define the set of strings
accepted by M this formula defines the
set of structures for which there is
some more
which results in a string that is
accepted by M right so if you if you
take this translate into this and then
translate back into a machine you don't
necessarily get the same set of strings
you get its closure under the
isomorphous emulation okay but that's
okay I mean this is this is sufficient
for proving the theorem okay not far
from here I'm faking or cigarette is the
math I'm a math department over here yes
in nineteen well i mean i guess the
thesis or 73-72 if you wanted to talk
about credits I think forgive us all the
creditors for this is looking like
spectrum survey paper okay John so much
intuition
it's true he formulated simply because
but I I to give only him the credit
lesson okay desserts okay we're I mean I
have to admit that as there's best lots
on my slides which is uncredited I mean
I'm treating this more as a you know as
coarse material so um i think we leave
discussions of credit for for the break
okay the question that follows and which
motivated a lot of work which is which
i'm going to talk about in the rest of
the talk is can we do something similar
for the class p okay so Chandler and
Harold pulls this question in a paper in
1982 and its remains as I said a major
open question in descriptive complexity
can we find a logic for polynomial time
in exactly the sense that for any class
of finite structures its definable in L
if and only if the set of strings that
encode it is decidable by a
deterministic polynomial time machine
okay now what is a logic l I mean as i
said chandler and hair loss this
question and the feeling is if you could
come up with a logical we would
recognize it as such but maybe the
answer is negative and what would what
would it mean to give a negative answer
to this right and gravich formulated
what a negative answer to this question
would be and conjecture that it is in
fact the case that there is no logic so
formally just said loose we have been a
very loose requirement the logical
should be a recursively enumerable set
of sentences with a computable map that
takes each sentence to a pair which is a
deterministic Turing machine and a
polynomial bound on it says that running
this machine to that bound actually
accepts the class of structures in other
words it's invariant under the
equivalence relation of structure
so we require that and then of course we
require that for every polynomial time
property there is a the other way around
the quest the second question was what's
under an arraylist and yuri formulated
in the version of it loads okay well no
no no I I think what was missing from
the Chandra and her formulation was
precisely this idea of a computable map
two pairs of my they also recursive a
new mobility but but Butler yeah I know
that's right but I mean the III think
this notion of a computable map to pair
it is crucial to make this I mean I in
gravity's paper he explicate many slight
variations and so shows that many of
them can be trivially answered and this
is the one that's the key so in other
words he was visibly saying there's no
no logically that that is Yuri's
conjecture formulated in here but there
is no logic for P and so in particular
piece different from NP you mean them no
not just that black ionization is not in
polynomial time that's true yes so you
actually believe that a bit
I don't yes I mean I mean I still think
that is possible right it's a there's a
right
so so what do we know about the
existence of logic copy I mean the
interesting work here starts with fixed
point logics which phone has sort of
introduced in the form of you know data
log which is the closure of existential
positive first order logic under fixed
points classically i mean i think the
was at aon old man who proposed a fixed
point logic for as a database query
language extending first-order logic
with with six points they suggested this
reduces you should give a logic
experience that I can I think close ok
ok ok but so I'm rather than least fixed
points I'm going to talk about
inflationary fixed points which gives
you an equivalent logic sub but let me
just formulate it so suppose we have a
formula first or logic in a vocabulary
which contains a Carrie relation are
right and let's say this formula has
free variables long x 1 to x k we
associate on it on a given structure a
which interprets all the relations other
than our so the sigma structure we think
of this formula as defining an operator
which given a Carrie relation defines
another one right so it takes a Carrie
relation plug in an interpretation for
our this formula then defines a Carrie
relation right and we call that fire far
ok so it's a map from Carrie relations
to carry relations now we will define
the following non-decreasing sequence of
relations and they start with the empty
relation at a neat stage take the
relation you have defined so far plug it
into this operator and add it to what
you had before so take the union this is
the inflationary nature of the operator
so it's an arbitrary operator but we
make sure the sequence is non-decreasing
by just taking all the couples we define
it I adding it to what we have so far
and we call the limit of the sequence
the inflationary fixed point because
this is a finite structure this limit is
reached at a finite stage
to be precise at most n to the K if
there are n elements of a I said say it
there okay and so we form the logic of
inflationary fixed points which I'll
just call FP by adding an operator which
allows you to define this relation
basically so if you have a formula for
vocabulary Sigma in your nalgas of
operator ifp which binds the relations
in Malhar and which basically defines
the relation which is the inflationary
fixed point and then you can write
construct a formula which says some
tuple is in that relation okay if
instead of inflationary fixed points I
had restricted these formulas to be say
positive in the formula are guaranteeing
their monotone I could take the least
fix point and I get something similar
but it's basically this allows me to
avoid this syntactic restriction to
positive formulas and it is known that
in terms of the expressive power the two
logics are the same whether you add
least fix points or inflationary fix
planes this was shown by gravity
inshallah back in 86 specifically for
finite structures and then culture
showed that even if you allow infinite
structures this is still the case okay
so that's the logical fixed points and
now here is just as an example take the
classic inductive definition transitive
closure and here's a formula which
defines the transitive closure of a
binary relation so strictly speaking
it's the reflexive intransitive
structure that I've defined over there
because as the base case i take x equals
y ok so
so the expressive power of expert logic
properly extends that of first-order
logic this already demonstrates that you
can easily define that a graph is
connected and I think in focus on
selection we saw a data log definition
of graph to color ability or graph non
to color ability but because this logic
is closed under negations we easily have
a definition of graph to color ability
which was another example we saw is not
definable in first order logic it's
still the case that every property
definable in this logic is in polynomial
time because as I said this induct any
inductive definition closes in a post n
to the K steps and each step involves
the evaluation of a first-order formula
which can be done in polynomial time
well as you allow nested inductions each
it's not necessarily a first-order
formula but still by induction every
property you can define is a computable
in polynomial time ok I've already said
this and what we know is that if you
restrict yourself to structures which
include a linear order that is the
interpreter linear order there's a
binary relation which is a linear order
the universe then every polynomial time
property can be expressed in this fixed
point logic and the reason is this we
call my quick one line statement of the
proof of the difficult direction of
[ __ ] theorem the non trivial one I
don't know if either one is trivial but
anyway I said from a non-deterministic
machine at a polynomial bound p we
construct this existential second order
sentence now we've started with a
deterministic machine and we don't have
to say there's a linear order because
one's already given to us so we can drop
this and then if the machine is
deterministic you can show that all the
relations that code the computation can
be defined inductively because there's a
single computation and the the the
relations which represented have a
simple inductive definition and so the
you get the translation into fixed point
logic
ok
but you can't I mean this restriction to
a linear order is important you can't
get rid of that you can't build up the
linear order inductively and this is
sort of what coucher was referring to
because it's an open question whether
you can come up with a canonical string
representation of a structure in
polynomial time whether there's a way of
constructing an order in a canonical
fashion by any polynomial time algorithm
if you could then we'd be done in a
sense if you could then we have a logic
for P in the gravitons and we also have
there for example graph isomorphism is
then in p if you can't the P is
different from NP right so either these
looks like a hard problem to solve but
that's of course that doesn't preclude
the possibility that you can prove there
is a logic for P by some other means
right without the canonical shrink
representations um no it's fuzzy Paulina
canonical string it's kind of
constructing it is quazy polynomial
thanks to Bob eyes does it only give us
more is more also canonical lately it's
bob icing it gives canonical it you can
yeah so um so can you know make explicit
so no I just Bobby's result tells us
that there is a quasi polynomial
algorithm which will construct a
canonical representation okay but yeah
that was it that was like okay I'll skip
this remark I don't think this is a well
maybe I'll say so here's one way of
thinking of it take all sentences or fix
my logic which may refer to an order
which is not interpreted by the
structure right but which are invariant
under the choice of four go which means
on any given structure whatever order
you choose either the sentence is true
or the sentence is false this collection
of sentences is in some sense a logic
for P every polynomial time property is
expressible and nothing else is but it's
not a recursively enumerable set of
sentences right because this invariance
property is undecidable and strongly so
but if you restrict yourself to fix my
logic itself right those sentences of x1
we don't refer to this order then it's
too weak to express all properties okay
why is this you can't even express that
the number of elements in this structure
is even write the most trivial property
that I said is not first-order definable
and this takes us back to I introduced
finite variable logic in the in the
first lecture right remember lk is the
first order formulas using only the
variables X 1 to X K and now if you look
at the inductive definitions you start
if you start with a formula which has k
variables all together then it turns out
that each of these 50 and then Phi 1 Phi
2 each of these
as a relation I mean you can is
definable by sentence in alt okay so
first order sentence or first sort of
formula i should say with 2k variables
will define Phi M on all structures and
the proof is an argument by induction on
the structure the formula basically 50
is the empty relation everywhere so
that's easy to define to define Phi M
plus 1 you take the formula Phi which we
know has K variables all together and
you replace all instances afar by the
definition of Phi M you have to do a bit
of renaming of variables to avoid
capture but the key point to remember is
still no sub formula contains more than
two cave variables at any point whatever
the value of M is and that was a key
point I said about limiting the total
number of variables so you can rename
variables to get it down so this means
that if you fix the size the structure
in this formula which is equivalent to
then Phi n to the K is definable by
formula of l2 k so the number of
variables here doesn't depend upon the
size of the structure that's the key
point right you can for any fixed size
you can translate it into a first-order
formula and the number of variables
doesn't depend upon the size which means
put another way for any property of
fixed point logic we can find a k so
that the formula is invariant under K
equivalents it's another way of saying
it is you can actually turn this formula
into a theory in lk it's equivalent to a
theory no can infinite collection of lk
sentences and we've already shown even
this is not definable with a fixed
number of variables we saw that with a
pebble game in the very first lecture so
even s is not definable in fixed much
logic we saw the existence of a perfect
matching in a graph is not definable we
saw hamiltonicity is not definable now
this is it seems less surprising this is
an np-complete problem you wouldn't
expect it to be definable but we
actually can prove it's not definable we
don't need to assume
the P is different in from MP to prove
it this is just the case okay now all of
these results all these in express
ability results seem to involve some
form of counting I say some form come
these don't these are not counting
properties this is a property which is
about counting besides the structure but
the examples that we used to prove the
perfect matching and hamiltonicity are
not definable all turn out to be simple
counting examples which is kind of what
led a memento back in the 1980s to
suggest we extend fixed point logic with
the mechanism for counting and maybe
that would give you all of polynomial
time so what is it what is the extension
let me define it quickly so our logic
has two sorts of variables so what I'm
going to present is not necessarily
amends original definition it's it's
tweaked slightly I mean over the years
is then we made a little bit cleaner we
have two sorts of variables in our logic
1 range is over the domain of the
structure as before and another which
range which ranges say over the
non-negative integers right
if you have a formula with a free
variable X and now X can actually be a
formula variable Phi the type we can
form a term which refers to the number
of elements in a which satisfy so the
number of elements X such that Phi is
true of X this is to be interpreted as
the number of element so we have
variables which ranges over numbers we
have terms which range over numbers on
number terms we have arithmetic
operations now on the face of it this is
getting far too rich because we have
just thrown in all of first-order earth
arithmetic it seems into our logic so we
limit quantification over a number of
variables so this really should be a new
so you can't you don't have unrestricted
quantification of the numbers because
that would take us well beyond
polynomial time into the realm of the
undecidable but you so any
quantification of our numbers has to be
bounded by a term ok inna mermans
original formulation these things only
arranged over numbers up to the size of
the structure but it seems follow you
know this allows you to arrange let them
range wider you know as long as it's
every every quantifier is bounded and
then you can show that the expressive
power entirely stays with in polynomial
time ok so fix my with counting as I
said you know at one point it was it was
suggested that this might capture
polynomial time it's not it doesn't and
I'm going to sort of tell you why to
analyze this it's useful again to go
back to first order logic and consider
an extension of first-order logic with
counting rather simpler than the one i
just presented we don't have two kinds
of variables instead we will have for
each fixed value i fixed positive
integer I a quantifier which exists
which says there exists I elements X
such that Phi ok but at the same time
like we did with lk we are going to
limit ourselves to the variables X 1 to
X K so note
this seat logic cks defined is actually
a fragment of first-order logic anything
you can translate this into a
first-order formula just by expanding
this into it I individual quantifiers
but the problem it's the combination of
the of the two if you do that you blow
up the number of variables so ck is
certainly not a fragment of hell k ck
even for fixed values of k is not a
fragment of lk prime for any again any k
prime right the translation doesn't you
can't translate with a bounded number of
variables but it's a well-defined
fragment of first-order logic and
therefore we can define the notion of
equivalence in this and it is still a
coarsening of elementary equivalent so
this is another stratification of
elementary equivalence okay because this
is a fragment of first-order logic and
we say and B are equivalent with respect
to formulas that appear in here and then
what you can show is every formula fixed
point with counting as defined on the
previous slide for each such sentence
there is AK says that it's in very
intended escapements this is again the
same idea you unfold the inductions by
substitution that keeps the number of
variables bounded and then you have to
sort of get rid of those number
variables using these counting
quantifiers instead and it's
I mean it's rather more work which i'm
not going to do at the moment but this
is it and so this elementary equivalence
relation the stratification of
elementary equivalence is our tool for
showing limitations on the power of
fixed point with County okay so FPC was
proposed as a set by Merman but already
in nineteen while I suppose 1989 was the
first version of this paper this refers
to the journal paper cipher and mm when
showed that there are polynomial time
properties of graphs that are not
expressible in fixed point accounting
okay now it's not I don't there isn't a
succinct statement of what of the
polynomial time property the show is not
definable but the construction enabled a
number of other results to follow okay
and the one I'm going to focus on is
this one which appears in paper by
Albert isn't here homebuilding Albert
under a lot of and myself we showed in
some sense a rather natural problem in
polynomial time the problem of solving
linear equations over the two element
field is polynomial-time solvable but
not expressible in fixed point with
counting
there are other things for instance I
mean
on my list of three examples of things
not definable in fixed point to logic
ahead even this perfect matching and
hamiltonicity even necessarily definable
once you've thrown in the counting
perfect matching it turns out the
existence of perfect matching is
definable this is not a straightforward
result but one I'll look at tomorrow
hamiltonicity you can still prove is not
definable in fixed point with counting
but that's something I'm not going to
get into there are the things like three
color ability which you can prove or not
definable but okay just as in a as an
illustration of the methods use I'm
going to focus on this one okay so this
is clearly solvable in polynomial time
yes Sam you have a slight ooh you're
saying that the quantification work
hasta villagers I it's the number
operator listen well I'm not saying it's
the same in the sense that if you added
these two fixed point logic you would
get something weaker because in any
formula you would have only finitely
many of these constants occurring but
this equivalence relation basically is
over all formulas and so you have an
infinite set of integers and what you
can do is you can show that a formula
fixed point logic can be unfolded in
with this sort of infinitely thing using
just these constant quantifiers express
things like which already e that's
that's right but but but but with an
infinite REE you know with a theory
effectively with an infinite set of
sentences right and okay
right so so this is a polynomial-time
solvable by means of course in
elimination and now we have to show that
it's not an fixed point with chanting
let's see so first of all what do I mean
by a system of linear equations as a
structure so I'm going to take my
structures to be on the following form
we have the universe it's going to be
the set of variables and a set of
equations ok that's the universe and now
we're every equation is basically for
some set of variables it's going to be
the sample breath
let me probably some over X in s Exel is
either 0 or 1 right so every equation is
just some over some set of variables
with a zero or one on the right hand
side so i'll have a unary relation for
those equations which I per 0 on the
right hand side another unity relation
for those equations which are the one on
the right hand side and a sort of the
matrix if you will which says that the
variable X occurs on the left hand side
of equation e ok one binary relation to
urinary relations and that's my system
of equations and now i have the class of
structures we should present solvable
systems is a well-defined class of
structures and I ask can i define this
an FPC will prove you can't and it's
clearly polynomial time decidable
because you just write this matrix out
do your usual gaussian elimination and
it gives you the answer so the show but
you can't do this in FP see what do I
need to do I need to give you for each K
two systems of equations one of which is
satisfiable the other isn't but they
cannot be distinguished in CKD right I
want to give you such a pair for each
value of K and that proved that'll prove
that you can't do this in FPC I mean
this property of being solvable is not
invariant hundred K continents ok so
there are two things first of all I'll
tell you what these systems of equations
are and then we'll look at what tools we
have for proving k equivalence I mean
we're going to need variations on these
pebble games we had before so I'm going
to start with a for regular connected
graph you see the reason for the four
before it's actually not you could get
you can get away with three but pick a
for regular connected graph so every
vertex has four neighbors and from this
i define i thought i'd fix this geez
anyway i define a system of equations
where the variables the set of variables
consists of the set of edges in the
graph with two variables for each age so
i have twice as many variables as i have
edges in the graph
right so i'll label I'll call these
variables x is 0 and X c1 whatever is an
edge by equations
for each vertex V let's say a vertex V
has four edges incident on it I mean
every vertex V has four edges incident
on it lets their ue 1 e 2 e 3 4 i'm
going to write down 16 equations
associated with that vertex and
basically these 16 equations are given
by this I take from each of the edges
one of the two variables that's my 16
choices and I say the some of them is
what I put on the right hand side is the
sum of those subscripts modulo 2 okay so
okay my gosh you're looking slightly
confused so I pause you're happy okay so
this is it this is a set of 16 equations
associated with each vertex V that's my
system of equations EG
now from EG i define a different one
which i'll call a tilde g which is
exactly the same but I pick one vertex V
at random and for that vertex I change
all the zeros to ones and all the ones
to zeros on the right-hand side ok so I
add one that's my system e.e till dig'
and the claim is first of all but this
original system is satisfiable the
second one isn't and then I'm going to
show that these if for suitably chosen G
and I'll have to explain to you what
that is these things are going to be
indistinguishable in CKD so first of all
let's just a bliss these claims about
satisfiability why is the satisfiable EG
is satisfiable further rather simple
reason that i said just set each
variable to the value of its subscript
and then obviously all of these
equations are satisfied why is the
system unsatisfiable well I'm just going
to give you a subset set of the
equations which are already inconsistent
and therefore the whole system
satisfiable and that's those in which
the only subscripts are 0 so basically
pick one equation from each vertex the
one where all the subscripts ABC dr0
right then all the right-hand sides are
0 except one ok
all the right hand side but if you sum
the left hand left hand side every
variable cure occurs twice because each
variable is associated with an edge and
that age has to two end points so every
variable occurs twice so something all
of these gives you 0 modulo 2 but the
right-hand sides add up to 1 because
they're all zeros except for exactly one
occurrence of 1 and therefore the system
is inconsistent ok so we have a
satisfiable system and an unsatisfiable
system and now we want to show that for
each k we can find a graph g which makes
these two ck equivalent and actually i
mean on my slides I've tried to do this
all explicitly but actually it's
sufficient interestingly enough because
this is a concept that has appeared it's
sufficient that the tree width of G is
bigger than K right I said it's for
regular and connected to define the
system if the tree roots of G is bigger
than k then these things are
indistinguishable in CKD and this ok
we'll get to the construction of G in a
moment how are we going to prove that
the ck equivalent we want a pebble game
and there is
if you looked at the pebble games we
define though an actual moves for each
for the existential quantifier right
existential quantifier on universal
quantifier you pick elements in the two
structures um Immelman and lander
defined a pebble game for ck how many of
you know landa well eric lander exactly
yes yeah i think also served on the
presidential Scientific Advisory
Committee for Obama and so anyway this
is not the result which got in that
appointment anyway so they define a
pebble game for ck equivalence right so
again we have spoiler and duplicator and
we have K pairs of pebbles okay and now
we want to move corresponding to these
counting quantifiers so think of it
essentially we have there exists I X
such that Phi and let's a spoiler is
asserting that this is true in one
structure and falls in the other how do
we do this spoiler picks a value of i
sorry not let's call this M okay
so here spoiler pics i mean spoil it
picks one of the pebbles that's why okay
and a set of elements of one structure
so basically say spoiler is asserting
this is true in be so pick a set of
elements that satisfy this duplicator
has to respond with a set of elements of
the other structure of exactly the same
size saying well there is a set in the
other set on the other side which also
has this property now spoiler says aha
you cheated you included something that
doesn't satisfy fine so spoiler picks an
element of the set that duplicator chose
and duplicator has to respond with an
element of the set that spoiler chosen
says but this one looks just like and
then the game moves on so at the end of
the round only two elements have been
selected but the process of selection
involves choosing these sets and they
have to be the same size okay I present
this because presently this way it's
kind of clear that it captures the sort
of semantics of this quantifier I is one
of these pebbles at any points what I
can move any one of the pebbles I ranges
from 1 to K alright they're capable k
pairs of pebbles the game whether to
chose which pebbles father is going to
put place and then places that AI on an
element of X and duplicate rest respond
with bi ok
right so this is the the usual kind of
connection this is a I mean it's in the
cybermen original construction this was
the game they used but actually it's
more convenient to describe in terms of
a bite action game are defined by Laurie
hella which is as follows its kind of
again we have two structures k pairs of
pebbles again spoiler chooses I the
pebbles that are going to move and
duplicator has to respond by giving a
bijection between the two two structures
right in some sense basically stating
for every possible move what the
response will be in one go and the
bijection has to respect the positions
that are already pebbled so for
everything other than I HHA you know of
the currently public position is
respected by this x direction wonder
then chooses some element of the
structure and the pebbles go on that
element and its image under the x
direction ok and if this thing is not a
partial isomorphism duplicator loses
this on the face if it looks much harder
for duplicator you're having to give a
bijection is having to respond to all
possible moves but it turns out to be
the same duplicator has a winning
strategy if and only if there's the two
structures are ck equivalent and very
quickly i can tell you why clearly if
duplicator has a winning strategy for
the x direction game then there's a
winning strategy in the counting game
because whenever spoiler chooses set you
just look at it semi done to the x
ejection and that gives you a set of the
same size in which to look at again play
for the other direction what you do is
you look at the equivalence on elements
introduced induced by the ck equivalents
so
ok
you have the structure a you have the
set the couple of currently public
positions you say that two elements are
whatever no okay so so so the point is
i'm assuming duplicator has a winning
strategy in the in the in the counting
game and i want to show the winning
strategy in the x direction team so look
at one move spoiler chooses i and and
then what duplicator does is look at the
following equivalence relation namely
look at the pep currently pebbled
positions look at what substituting if
substituting a for the I exposition and
a prime for the ith position result in
ck equivalent positions we say these two
things are equivalent basically these
two moves you know are equivalent as far
as the game is concerned for each of
these equivalence classes by the
assumptions of the counting game
duplicator has a response which is a set
of the same size and then you stitch
these sets of the same size together to
construct a bijection between the two
and that gives you can show that that's
a winning move in the badge action game
okay
ah so this is the tool for showing two
structures are equivalent remember what
we're after there was these systems of
equations we constructed from a graph
now I said that the graph has tree with
that most the assumption of the graph
has tree with at least K and what I'm
going to use is a characterization of
free with in terms of cops and robbers
games I'm not going to tell you why this
is characterization I'll just use the
cops and robbers games and I'll just
show you an example of a graph where
this works so so you don't need to know
its equivalent but it's just an
interesting fact so cops and robbers
game is the following game we have an
undirected graph and we have two players
the cop player and its robber player the
cop player controls a team of K cops and
the robber controls a robber at any
given point so the robber player
controls are over let's say is at any
given point all these these k cops and
robbers sit on vertices of the graph
what does one move consist of so the
cops are sitting on some set of at most
K vertices robberies on some vertex are
the cop player chooses some set of cops
which are going to move and announces
the position they're going to move to ok
and move I mean these cops have
helicopters they just fly and land
anywhere else on the graph right they
they're not constrained by the graph
structure at all they just they're going
to move the robber is constrained by the
graph and the robber can move from the
current position to any position as long
as there's a path from r 2 s not just
one step any path but the path must not
go through any of the stationary cops
which are acting as guards ok
this leads to a new position the robber
is now in position s and the cops are
now basically in all the all the ones
that didn't move plus the new positions
in the middle thing it is good the path
is allowed to go through the Y vertices
yes go through them yes so it sits on
them at the end that's right if the if
the Rope if a cop and robber end up on
the same node the robber is caught and
the game is over okay so so the point is
I don't know if I I think I have it
somewhere on the slide but it's worth
mentioning now this is a
characterization of tree width right
they do in the sense that if you can
show that a graph has tree with greater
than K if and only if robber has a
strategy for winning against a team of K
cops ok basically if the graph is
sufficiently interconnected the robber
has a strategy for avoiding k cops
they're always paths so i'll give you
just an example because all I need is
one such graph and the graph I chose is
a k by k / roydell grid what do I mean
by this
I mean a grid which is K by K and by
toroidal I just mean we also have edges
which go around so think of this
embedded on a torus and notice this is
for regular which is why I chose for
regular graphs at the beginning and once
you have a k by k grid this has three
words greater than k 0 or more to the
point I can show that explicitly the
robber has a winning strategy in the
cake cops and robbers game why is this
suppose at any given position the robber
the cops are sitting on a set of X of
vertices on a set of at most capable
vertices right and I argue that the
graph that remains when you remove those
X contains a connected component with at
least half the vertices ok why is this
well if all the vertices are indistinct
rows then removing them just leaves a
connected graph right because you know
you remove one node from each row you
can always get around to every point in
the row and so on so if they're not a
distinct rose then there is at least one
row right which contains none so it's
connected to every column right and it
contains in at least half the columns k
minus 1 vertices and it's come in a
connected component because to
disconnect the whole column you need to
so you can connect disconnected most
half the columns from it ok and that's
it so if you remove k vertices they're
all there's always a connected component
with at least half the verdict with at
least half the vertices and now Robert
strategy is simply described stay in the
big component right
so I had mentioned to you when I talked
about three words that the grid you know
has tree with a minimum of its
dimensions and i gave you sort of an
upper bound by describing the
decomposition this is how you show the
lower bound okay but right and we're
kind of done now really good right so so
stay in large component and avoid the
wise right I mean somehow well no the
point is at any point the sum of the
robbers some of the cops are moving so
the and you know where they're going to
land right so the the large component in
the previous movement a large component
of the next move must overlap right so
you can move there's a path from the
current position into the overlap you go
there and stay there ok so I I mentioned
this the cops and robbers game actually
characterize this tree width so it just
it would have been enough to just say
we're taking a graph of luxury and now
what does this have to do so now I want
to claim that once you have this we're
going to combine the robber winning
strategy right on whitacre and turn the
robber winning strategy in G into a
winning strategy for duplicator in the x
direction game played on these two
systems of equations we constructed from
g and the idea is this at any point we
have k pebbles placed on these two
systems of equations
and let's say a bijection between these
two systems is good bar V vertex B in in
the graph G if it's an isomorphism
everywhere except for the variables and
edges incident on V sorry for variables
which correspond to edges incident on be
so the point is remember we constructed
these two systems of equations which
were the same except for at one vertex
you can define an isomorphism which is a
map by ejection which is I isomorphism
except at one point in the graph let's
call that a bisection which is good bar
V you can show that if you have a
bisection which is good bar V and a path
from V to you then you can construct the
by ejection which is good bar you so
isomorphism everywhere except around you
by changing the x jection just at the
vertices corresponding to the path from
video so this the idea is simple it's
the ejection is where the inconsistency
in the equations is that a certain
vertex and you have an edge for the for
the two variables that correspond to
this edge you interchange the 0 in the
one that makes it consistent over here
and inconsistent over here and you can
repeat this process along any path right
and now
in the bisection came duplicator place
these my actions that are good except on
a single vertex corresponding to the
current robber position in the in the
cops and robbers game so basically we're
playing this by jackson game the
duplicator on the side has a copy of the
cops and robbers game and where the
pebbles move treats that as a move by
cops on the on this finds a path for
Robert to take and changes the by
jection along a path makes no changes
where the where the pebbles actually
appear because that's what the robber
strategy guarantees and the
inconsistency between the two systems is
always hidden at a position where there
are no pebbles because that's what the
cops and robbers game guarantees okay
okay I'm running out of time so I that's
it for this proof and I just let me just
sort of say little very quick survey of
other work in this area it turns out now
fixed point we're camping sorry it's not
all of polynomial time by that proof we
just gave it turns out it's incredibly
powerful already a member and Lander
showed that it well all properties of
trees polynomial time properties of
trees are in their extended to all
graphs are bounded tree with any
property of graphs a boundary with in
polynomial time can be expressed in FPC
which already tell explains why we had
to use unbounded tree with graphs in our
proof in fact ah FBC captures beyond the
class of all planar graphs and this sort
of stunning result i say 2010 I mean of
course this is still in the course of
publication because the proof huh the
proof is a 450 page monograph but on any
minor closed class of graphs fixed
bible-thumping captures all polynomial
time properties and on all of these the
proof essentially proves that you can
construct a canonical ordered
representation of a graph in the class
and that can be done in in fixed point
with counting so not just in polynomial
time but in fix part of accounting
I'm yeah it sort of begs the question
what about these nowhere dense graphs so
what's known about let's move to bangla
dick that's right exactly this
construction already gives you a bounded
degree class on which it fails yes yes
so 3 shows that you have to use it to
relapse no no because I mean the when I
construct when I convert the so I
started with this graph and then I
turned dice into systems of equations
you could encode those systems of
equations as graph gadgets which is what
sort of cipher and I'm a merman
originally did and that doesn't preserve
the topological properties at all so in
fact you can even though you start with
a toroidal one once you do the guys it's
the parcel you get is doesn't exclude
any minors you can show that in fact
well it would contradict this meaning of
this state so any property of polynomial
time property of planar graphs is
expressible in fixed point without thing
just that they're definitely not planar
I mean if you turn them into a graph I
mean or if you look at the guys man
graph of these equations it's definitely
not planar right ok and so my last slide
I wanted to say a few so what can we add
to FPC while remaining inside p now that
we know that spc is a proper fragment of
polynomial time how we've looked at
logics with matrix ranks a rank operator
or finite fields this is actually in
some sense specifically designed to
address the one problem we know here are
the systems of linear equations if you
had an operator for computing the rank
of a matrix you could express that so
it's clearly strictly more powerful but
so what maybe a more interesting one is
this choiceless polynomial time defined
by under us here along with urien sauron
chela which is based on a machine model
rather than a logic but it satisfies the
garage criterion for logic ok the idea
is a machine model that works directly
on a relational structure rather than on
strings
and this class is then the polynomial
time and space restriction of these
machines both of these can you know fix
fine with rank and choiceless polynomial
time with counting our can be proved to
be strictly more expressive than fixed
point with counting but their
relationship to each other and their
relationship to pee I think all remain
open questions we don't know that either
of these includes the other we don't
know that either of them is properly
included in p what we need is new tools
for analyzing the expressive power you
see so we've been building up from tools
for first-order logic fix biologics fix
pilot counting and here we are now in
new territory okay and this is where I
want to stop for today questions just to
make sure I'm not mentally
oversimplifying something in these
systems of equations its structure
actually has variables and the equations
but in the duplicators strategy that
nothing ever happens with the equations
each other well of course spoiler can
put a pebble on an equation and and
since an equation corresponds to a
vertex you go back and put a put a
rubber on that vertex in the graph and
it still works right I mean I could have
because I limited to four regular graphs
I could have just put in just the
variables as the universe and encoded
all the equations into relations I gave
the general form because actually you
know at one point us think of writing
the general argument with an arbitrary
graph you know it not a pound a degree
and so on general connection between the
cops and robbers
the cake pebble rejection game idiot
once played on one graph we always
played on two graphs but do something
like some summer product for garage is
there some general result of transfers
winning status of one to the other
I don't know no III don't have anything
quite like that I mean this is this
sounds it seems there should be
something they should we study for this
particular yeah yeah that's a good
question buttock so the graph of system
the system of equations that you cause
try to cover like this it is almost
ordered because if you put an order on
yeah and it just it's a certain
structure of a small and all of it
exactly exactly i mean but yeah it
seemed like we're still just scratching
the surface of the problem because
feeling very easy no no this is right
and in fact so so cipher and emerman in
their original proof point out this fact
that this thing is what they call
bounded color class size right so
there's a way of coloring a definable
coloring in fact of this where the size
of each color class is bounded by about
four or three or four for now in fact
803 but properly difficult yeah now
that's that that's a very good yeah we
okay would you consider properly
difficult in which sense because I mean
if we if we had a craft colonization
algorithm for all of us out then the
whole thing yeah but but I mean I think
there is something here I think there's
something to what Bartok is saying in
the sense there are some results I think
Lipkin and somebody on what they call
almost ordered graphs you know this is
structures which I mean even more almost
ordered than this in the sense that
there's a linear order except on some
logarithmic number of elements where you
have a pre-order where they post two or
three and they show that a lot of
capturing results which working on
ordered grass fail or you know rather
badly with just if you you know a lot as
with this minimal amount of non or
so that the boundary between ordered and
unordered is is sharp in that sense yes
there's that happens to be the case is
that so this structure can be can be
represented at the graph ladies on all
the bits of them six yeah it's the
minimum I mean if you patches all right
for you see soon what's coming to see
okay no I think well I don't know but
maybe for this particular graphs but in
general spc can express all polynomial
time properties on graphs with color
class size three but already on for it
fails you can construct examples with
color class size for where it fails yeah
okay what are the results and choices
polynomial time capturing a certain of
these permit cutter class cases where
you have an a billion I'll be the
instructor ando on the kind of classes I
that's right that's right rection one
has come quite a bit further okay I
think we should stop here and take a
break